The first trailer for Marvel's Ant-Man and
the Wasp is here, and while it might contain
exactly zero hints about what's to come in
the MCU movies that precede it — namely,
Black Panther and The Avengers: Infinity War
— there are plenty of clues about what lies
ahead for its title characters in the second
Ant-Man movie.
So, pull out your magnifying glasses and search
along with us as we break down some of the
smallest details to be found in the first
trailer for Ant-Man and the Wasp.
A new Ant-thony
One of the saddest moments in Ant-Man was
certainly the loss of Ant-thony, Scott Lang's
trusty winged ant pal who carried him through
trials large and small.
The creature was well-trained, quirky, and
had a knack for arriving right in the nick
of time.
However, with Hope van Dyne's new Wasp suit
equipped with its own set of wings, Scott's
gonna need some aerial transportation for
the new flick himself.
"So, I take it you didn't have that tech available
for me?"
"No, I did."
So, as we see in the trailer, he'll have to
let his memory of Ant-thony go and make a
new pal from the Formicidae family to buzz
around town with.
Frankly, Ant-thony 2.0 could be from the original's
own colony for how much they look alike, and
what's even better is, it looks Lang's new
ride can keep pace with the Wasp, too.
Here's Ghost
We don't know for sure whether Ghost, portrayed
by Hannah John-Kamen, will be the biggest
bad of Ant-Man and the Wasp.
But we do know that the mysterious character
will be coming along to spook our insectoid
heroes a bit.
The trailer offers not one but two glimpses
of the villainess in action.
In the first sighting, we see Ghost's hand,
radiating with trippy energy from that white
stealth suit.
In the second shot of the character, we see
Ghost in a full slate gray costume, concealing
any trace of her humanity and leaving us instead
with the red-eyed antagonist.
Behold, Goliath
Another first-glimpse of a new MCU character
featured in the Ant-Man and the Wasp trailer
is that of Bill Foster a.k.a. Goliath, a.k.a.
comics' second Giant-Man, played by Laurence
Fishburne, in what looks like Hank Pym's lab.
It's not clear whether Foster will be in his
pre- or post-Goliath glory days by the time
he arrives in the Ant-Man sequel, but Fishburne
has hinted that he'll be both a "hero" and
scientist in the movie.
Whether that means he's retired his super
suit or not remains to be seen.
Super size me
It looks like Giant-Man will be making a comeback
in Ant-Man and the Wasp as well.
Scott Lang usually uses his power to shrink
down to a fun-sized superhero.
But in Captain America: Civil War, he tried
his hand at blowing up to fight all Cap's
frenemies.
Ant-Man might've needed some fresh fruit after
it was all said and done to recover from the
experience, but for the most part he handled
himself just fine.
From the looks of this trailer, he'll be giving
Bay Area folks quite a surprise when he emerges
from the water in hypersize for some reason.
Maybe his suit's regulator gets out of whack
again, but Hank Pym should probably develop
a memory-erasure device next because this
is one sight San Franciscans are not likely
to forget.
"I do some dumb things."
Missing in action
Two of the most intriguing cast additions
for Ant-Man and the Wasp are Michelle Pfeiffer
as Janet van Dyne a.k.a. the original Wasp,
and Walton Goggins as Sonny Burch, a smarmy
weapons developer.
It's expected that, thanks to Scott Lang's
prior visit to the Quantum Realm, Hank Pym's
going to order up a mission to get the original
Wasp back from said plane of micro-existence,
however long that might take.
The trailer betrays none of that plotline,
however, and it also tells us nothing about
what to expect from Burch.
In the comics, he's a relatively small character
who gets into a tiff with Tony Stark's company.
But since Iron Man isn't expected to have
anything to do with this movie, the running
theory is that he'll be taking over for the
late Darren Cross a.k.a. Yellowjacket over
at Cross Technologies.
We'll have to wait for the film, or at least
a more revealing trailer, to find out more
about either of these theory threads, but
clearly, Marvel's keeping both of these exciting
character debuts close to the chest for now.
The microscopic realm
Our title heroes might not make way to the
Quantum Realm just yet in the film's trailer,
but it does look like at least someone will
be shrinking down to the microscopic plane.
In one snapshot from the trailer, the team's
rocket-submarine can be seen drifting through
a cloud of tardigrades, of all things.
Since the micro-animals are known to be water-dwelling
creatures, we can surmise that Hank & Co.
are going to be travelling somewhere wet before
getting to an even tinier realm.
Any excuse to show adorable water bears, right?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!